[تصفيق]
الله اكبر من الينوي الى فيرمونت ومن
نيويورك الى فلوريدا حوادث راوحت بين قتل
واطلاق نار ومضايقات وطرد من المدارس
والوظائف بعضها سجلت حوادث كراهيه واخرى
قيد التحقيق بحق عرب وفلسطينيين ومسلمين
منذ بدء الحرب على
غزه في شيكاجو قتل الطفل الفلسطيني
الامريكي وديع الفيومي الذي بلغ من العمر
ست سنوات بطعنه 26 مره من قبل ملك العقار
الذي يسكنه مع والدته في جريمه
كراهيه وفي فلوريدا فصلت مدرسه ثانويه جاد
ابو حمده الفلسطينيه الامريكيه البالغه من
العمر 15 عاما بعد ان انتقدت والدته وهي
معلمه عبر وسائل التواصل وحشيه اسرائيل ضد
الفلسطينيين وفي فيرمونت اطلق رجل النار
على ثلاثه شبان جامعيين فلسطينيين
لارتدائهم الكوفيه الفلسطينيه وتحدثهم
بالعربيه هذا في حين اعتقلت الشرطه في
جورجيا بنجمين ريس استاذ الاجتماعيات بعد
ان هدد طالبه بقطع راسها اثر اعتراضها على
رفع علم اسرائيل في
الصف بنتي الحمد لله هي هي منيحه هلا طلاب
المدرسه كانوا
كثير داعمين بشكل نفس بشكل قوي
نفسيا ما حدا ابدا لا من المدير ولا من
المدرس
ولا من من اللي بيعرفوا على الموضوع لانه
هم بحاولوا
يخفوا هي مين عشان ما ما
تنزي بس مين ما عرف عن الموضوع كان يجي
ويعطيها يعني هاجز ويع يعني يحضنها ويقول
لها انه هي عملت منيح وانها ما حكت ولا
شيء
غلط مجلس العلاقات الامريكيه الاسلاميه
كير سجل في المده ما بين السابع من اكتوبر
والثاني من ديسمبر
271 شكوى لحوادث معاديه للمسلمين
والفلسطينيين قبل السابع من اكتوبر كانت
الشكاوى تاتينا باستمرار لكن ضمن الوثيره
التي كنا نتوقعها منذ السابع من اكتوبر
وحتى الان هذه الوثيره عاليه جدا وما زلنا
نستقبل الشكاوى وحالات الاعتداء سواء من
جرائم للكراهيه او محاولات كبت الاصوات في
الجامعات وفي الوسط الاكاديمي وفي المد
وقد لاقت بعض الحوادث كقتل الطفل وديع
الفيومي واطلاق النار على الطلاب
الفلسطينيين في فيرمونت ردود فعل مندده من
البيت الابيض والمشرعين وتاكيدا ان لا
مكان للكراهيه في المجتمع الامريكي لكن
اوساط كثيره ترى ان موقف الاداره لا يرقى
الى حجم المشكله بل قد يكون مؤجج
لها لم تفعل هذه الاداره ما يكفي تذكر
الاسلاموفوبيا حين تذكر معادا الساميه لكن
لا تساوي بينهما ما تقوم به الاداره من
خلال الخطاب والتصرفات تفضيل لحمايه
اليهود ومحاربه معادات الساميه اكثر من
حمايه المسلمين والعرب والفلسطينيين
ومحاربه صعود الاسلاموفوبيا منذ السابع من
اكتوبر على مستوى الولايات راينا دعم
بعضها للمسلمين في حين راينا ملاحقه في
ولايات اخرى وهنا يمكن للحكومه الفيدراليه
التدخل بالقول انها ليست الطريقه الملائمه
للتعامل مع المسلمين البيت الابيض اعلن
مطلع نوفمبر تطوير اول استراتيجيه وطنيه
لمكافحه الاسلاموفوبيا لكن الاستراتيجيه
لم تتضح معالمها بعد وفي حين تستمر الحرب
بما تحمله من قتل ودمار لا تتوقف محاولات
تشويه صوره المحتجين ضدها بان ابو كويك
الجزيره واشنطن ah